I think the first time we met each other
was around 20 years ago when you were
still stiff of stuff of Odin Senator Joe
Biden but you started your career as a
lawyer how come that most of your
professional life you have devoted to
the security and foreign policy of your
country the United States of America
well you know Rob I had the great
experience of having been born in New
York drawing up actually outside of the
United States from age 9 to 18 in Paris
and France and when you have that
experience you learn to see your own
country from and through the eyes of
others and you wind up spending a lot of
time defending your country but also
thinking about it it's it's great
strengths as well as its its weaknesses
and I think that instilled in me a great
interest in foreign policy in diplomacy
and in thinking about how peoples from
different different nationalities
cultures backgrounds can can get along
and while I did do a number of different
things ultimately I wound up in
government working on foreign policy and
I've done that until leaving the Obama
administration for the last 25 years
right starting out with Bill Clinton
working then in the White House for him
going on to the United States Senate for
the Foreign Relations Committee that Joe
Biden was then the chairman and then
finally the last eight years working for
President Obama in one capacity or
another you know we're all the product
to some extent of our own stories our
own narratives our own family histories
and in my case I had many immediate
relatives who were recent immigrants to
the United States or even refugees my
father's father my grandfather came here
at the turn of the last century fleeing
pogroms in in Russia he was welcomed
into the United States and built a life
and contributed my stepmother fled
communism and Hungary literally in the
middle of the night as a young girl
getting on a train with her mother a
sham marriage that allowed her to come
to the United States be welcomed by the
United States build a life here and
contribute and then finally my
stepfather who passed away your so ago
he was one of nine
children in his hometown school in
Bialystok Poland but the only one who
survived and he spent the war in all of
the unfortunately infamous concentration
camps
Dachau Maidan ik hush wits and at the
very end of the war he was on a death
march from one of the camps and he made
a run for it in the bavarian forest and
he made it to the woods and he hid out
in the woods for a couple of days and
then he heard a rumbling sound and he
looked out and instead of seeing the
dreaded swastika he saw a five-pointed
white star and he ran for the white star
on a tank and the hatch of the tank
opened and an African American GI looked
down at him and he got down on his knees
and he said the only three words in
English that he knew that his mother had
taught him before the war god Bless
America and the G I picked him up lifted
him into the tank into the United States
in effect and into freedom
that's the country that I know that's
the country that I grew up learning
about that's the country that I hope
will remain at the forefront of freedom
and hope for people around the world in
this 21st century why is freedom not
self-evident
I think in a sense it is self-evident to
the extent that it is perhaps the
highest aspiration of human beings
everywhere but it's not self-evident in
its realization because we're dealing
with human beings and because we're
dealing with other elements of human
nature that sometimes make freedom on a
personal level or even at a national
level challenging to to achieve and so
it's dealing with all of those different
human elements to get to a place where
that value that is a universal value not
a Western value not an American value
where that value is able to come come to
the fore but ultimately we're dealing
with human nature and it's different
manifestations Europe remains the
partner of first resort for the United
States whenever we have a challenge
around the world our reflex is to look
first to Europe sometimes to countries
in that our individual capacity
sometimes to the European Union as a
collective and most Americans continue
to believe in the European construction
project I think part of the challenge
has been that further and further we get
away from the reasons that the EU came
into being in the first place the easier
it is to forget and not to give place
value in that and so when one is
familiar even in the slightest with the
history of Europe as well as the United
States in the 20th century you're
reminded why the EU is such an important
project to begin with but generations
today are far removed from that so I
think we have to remind ourselves of
what brought this project about in the
first place but then like anything it's
not just about defending something it's
about amending it as necessary to better
reflect the times to make it effective
to make sure that it's working for more
people and right now the divide that we
see in the world increasingly especially
in the United States and Europe is not
between left and right or conservative
or liberal or ribbon our case Republican
and Emma
it's between those who believe that
faced with these incredible forces of
change our best bet is to remain open
connected and to try to shape them to
our advantage and those who believe that
the best answer is to protect ourselves
available offensive it's between the
difference between those who had build a
wall and those who had continued to
build bridges
that's the divide that's the debate
that's what we have to reckon with